c'est peut dire que le logement connaît
une crise extrêmement grave historique
et c'est aussi madame la ministre le
résultat du fiasco de votre gouvernement
depuis 6 ans on a cette année 30 % de
construction de logement neuf en moins
on a dans le logement social on va
probablement pas dépasser 90000 nouveaux
logements sociaux alors qu'il y a 6 ans
on était encore à
125000 sur ce dossier vous faites de
l'argent 10 milliards sur action
et vous avez des discours mais
malheureusement même le ministre ne
considère pas que c'est un débat
essentiel alors vous en appelez à la
responsabilité des élus locaux il y a
des élus locaux qui font le boulot et
qui font bien le boulot notamment sur
une initiative que vous avez mentionné
le le bail réel
solidaire la ville de Lyon par exemple
planifie 1000 BRS par an et bien dans ce
cas-là madame qu'est-ce que vous en
envisager pour que la banque des
territoires qui doit être l'outil en
faveur de ce type d'instrument
massifie mobilise beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus de financement pour que les offices
fonciers puissent investir et de faire
de cette accession à la
semiprpriété Une une réussite en France
merci merci madame la
ministre monsieur le Président je vous
remercie monsieur le sénateur jade là
pour le coup vous faites une prise de
parole politique à laquelle je ne vais
pas répondre de façon politique mais de
la façon la plus précise possible encore
une fois vous êtes en train de poser un
diagnostic et et vous accuser le
gouvernement moi j'ai envie de de vous
dire que les propositions que vous
faites en conclusion de votre prise de
parole ben elles sont à l'œuvre vous
nous parlez du BRS qui a voté le BRS
c'est notre gouvernement et c'est depuis
2017 que nous avons
porté
ce ce
BRS ce BRS qui nous est si cher et dont
vous ventez les mérites moi je fais
partie de ceux qui dans les zones
tendues dans les zones dans lesquelles
les mètres carrés est très élevés le BRS
est très utile ensuite vous demandez à
ce que la banque des territoires
intervienne de façon beaucoup plus
massivement mais elle est actionnaire
aujourd'hui de tous les offices fonciers
de tous et donc aujourd'hui elle joue
pleinement son rôle là où on peut
peut-être diverger mais c'est l'ancienne
élu local qui va vous parler c'est que
vous attendez peut-être de l'État qu'il
dicte aux collectivités locales comment
ils doivent embarquer tel ou tel
dispositif et là on est dans la libre
administration de nos collectivités et
effectivement les collectivités sont
teintés deci de là des politiques
publiques qu'elles portent et donc nous
on est là pour mettre les outils pour
poser le même diagnostic que vous pour
trouver des outils pour accélérer
l'accession sociale comme l'accession
classique à la propriété qui fait partie
de notre socle et sur lequel nous
travaillons
assisument